[Musik]
remo heartbreaking ettling seit dem
dritten mai 2007 ist sie einfach
verschwunden aus dieser ferienanlage an
der portugiesischen algarve risch alle
kennen die geschichte
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
[Musik]
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer weiteren episode von
tatort deutschland dies ist der erste
teil einer doppelfolge zu einem der
berühmtesten kriminalfälle unserer zeit
wir sind dem möglichen täter in den
nächsten beiden folgen unseres podcasts
dicht auf den fersen denn es gibt brand
aktuelle entwicklungen in diesem fall
ihr alle werdet schon davon gehört haben
der fall maddie mccann
ich war damals korrespondent für bild in
london knapp dort im büro über britische
nachrichtenkanäle erfahren dass da was
passiert ist und das hat dann am
nächsten tag und auch in den tagen
darauf die nachrichten in england
komplett dominiert dann ist auch hier
langsam durchgesickert dass das ein
verbrechen von ungewöhnlichem ausmaßes
bild reporter kai feldhaus spürt im mai
2007 sofort dass die meldungen der
englischen boulevardpresse über ein
vermisstes mädchen im beliebten
portugiesischen urlaubsort dreier der
los erst der anfang eines großen falles
sind ganz großbritannien bank von anfang
an mit den eltern der verschwundenen
maddie mccann teilt deren ängste und
befürchtungen karl feldhaus überlegt
nicht lange und bringt die geschichte
nach deutschland
ich kann
schwerlich über reißen wie viele artikel
ich zum fall mary schon geschrieben habe
dutzende
wenn ich lief schau und meinen namen
eingeben und dann fast mir da rein was
im bild erschienen ist im bild am
sonntag und auch bild online dann kommen
wir wahrscheinlich auf 100 artikeln
wahrscheinlich im jahr der jung
gebliebene journalist fühlt sich in
seinem berliner büro durch die berge
alter und neuer artikel die im laufe der
letzten 15 jahre zum fall maddie aus
seiner feder entstanden sind es ist ein
fall der ihn hier zwischen designer
möbeln und kühlem sichtbeton nicht in
ruhe lässt
entschließt sich für tatort deutschland
noch einmal den spuren des größten
vermisstenfalls europas zu folgen und
licht in die grauenvolle dunkelheit
dieses verbrechens zu bringen
[Musik]
das meer glitzert den dreier der los es
ist ein traum ort für viele nordeuropäer
allen voran für briten aus dem
verregneten england immer auf der suche
nach sonne kai feldhaus ist hierher
gereist um uns vor ort von seinen
recherchen zu berichten sein groß
leinenhemd weht in der küsten brise die
braungebrannte stirn unter den kurzen
dunklen haaren hat schon etwas zu viel
sonne abbekommen ich bin immer wieder
selbstständig an diesem zwiespalt zu
sehen die paradiese schönen reihe da los
ist zu verstehen dass dieser ort jetzt
stellvertretend steht für eines der
größten verbrechen die
kriminalgeschichte
das fällt mir immer wieder schwer aber
ist es auch ebenso wichtig dann immer
mal hin zu sein ich war 2017 das
vorletzte mal hier
und zwar zum zehnten jahrestag des
verschwindens von kai feldhaus kennt
sich aus in den blitzsauberen städtchen
der ort ist von appartement häusern und
hotels der mittleren bis gehobenen
preisklasse geprägt der tourismus
durchdringt alles die menschen hier
leben gute von die gastronomie des ortes
ist immer gut besucht so auch die bar
des appartement komplexes ocean club in
dem maddie mccann zusammen mit ihren
eltern kate und gerry mccann ferien
macht bild-reporter feldhaus blinzelt in
die untergehende sonne von einer anhöhe
aus kann er die ferienanlage gut
überblicken am abend des dritten mal
2007 sitzen sie ins eltern hier im tapas
bar auf der anderen seite des pools beim
amt ist das appartement war von der
tapas-bar auszusehen man konnte terrasse
sehen den eingang ist der vorletzte
abend ihres urlaubs hier in praia da luz
in portugal die mccanns sitzen zusammen
mit drei befreundeten familie die
erwachsenen wechseln sich alle halbe
stunde ab und nach dem schlafen kindern
zu sehen gegen 22 uhr ist merkels mutter
kate an der reihe sie verlässt an sich
tapas-bar läuft einen monat lang um zu
appartement 5 das ocean club zu gelangen
das hier im erdgeschoss des gebäudes ist
um sie im appartement zu kommen muss
kate mir gern durch die rezeption und
über diese kleinen straße laufen die
tapas bar gehört zu dem appartement
komplex ist aber auch für gäste von
außerhalb geöffnet daher muss kate
diesen kleinen umweg machen der sie aber
vielleicht nur 30 sekunden kostet das
ist nichts besonderes
das machen alle wohl aber hier genauso
das zimmer ihrer tochter mit tritt sie
zunächst fest dass sie ein winzer in
denen auch unbemerkt an land nicht mehr
im bett feldhaus ist die paar schritte
zu der anlage hinab gegangen von einem
kleinen personal parkplatz aus kann ein
vergittertes fenster des apartments
sehen dieses fenster steht weit offen
kurz darauf ist sie schreien wieder raus
gelaufen und hat gerufen
allerdings wechselt ist verschwunden
jemand hat sie bis heute fehlt von
maddie mccann jede spur der alptraum für
die familie mit kern beginnt in diesem
moment
die sonne ist untergegangen
die straßenbeleuchtung flammt auf und
sofort fliegen die motten zum licht
flattern so lange bis sie tot auf dem
gehweg fallen kai feldhaus betrachtet
nachdenklich die ferienanlage von der
lachenden herüber schallt wie können
eltern ihr kleines kind immer partners
schlafen lassen werden sie essen gehen
ich glaube wenn man sich das vor ort
anschaute das vor ort erläutert dann
versteht man dass das gar nicht so
abwegig ist jetzt zehn fünfzehn jahre
später nachdem so etwas passiert ist
kann man sagen die kamera denn und die
kinder schlafen lassen und alleine und
so ich halte das gar nicht für so
wahnsinnig abwegig die eltern waren
keine 50 meter luftlinie entfernt sie
haben regelmäßig nachgeschaut jetzt im
nachhinein wenn man weiß dass sowas hier
passieren kann dann ist es einfach in
der vorwürfe zu machen und diese
vorwürfe gegen die mccanns werden immer
lauter man verdächtigt sie nach einiger
zeit sogar die kleine blonde mandy mit
den blauen augen ihre eigene tochter
verschwinden lassen zu haben kai
feldhaus ist schon lange an diesem fall
dran und trifft dazu regelmäßig auch den
ex ermittler und profiler axel petermann
er ist vielen durch seine bücher und
vielleicht auch durch sein markantes
schlohweißes langes haar aus tv talks
bekannt petermann schöpft sein wissen
aus 39 jahren polizeiarbeit carhartt
profiler petermann vor seiner abreise
nach portugal kurz getroffen was
passiert wenn ein kind verschwindet
um das zu verstehen habe ich mich mit
dem experten axel petermann verabredet
ich möchte von ihnen wissen wie er
vorgegangen wäre hätte er vielleicht die
eltern als erstes genauer unter die lupe
genommen
also die erste alarm das ist klar
verwandte dass familienangehörige seien
könnten finde ich berechtigt weil wir
denken es war immer das glück dass die
familie ein hort der geborgenheit ist
der zuneigung füreinander da sein aber
der alltag zeigt uns doch genau das
gegenteil das ist etwas verzögern ich
ran wollen wo wir uns abwenden aber es
ist leider real und deswegen muss man an
eine solche möglichkeit denken muss sich
sehr genau mit den spuren die es dort an
diesem ort des verschwindens gibt
auseinandersetzen und muss sich mit den
einlassungen der betroffenen
auseinandersetzung um dann zu sagen ich
bin wichtig oder aber ich muss eine
andere werden
auf
maddies eltern beginnen damals sofort
mit der medialen kampagne die die suche
nach ihrem kind unterstützen soll
spätestens zu diesem zeitpunkt kennt
jeder auf der welt das schicksal des
britischen ärzte paares aus schrott lee
in leicestershire nur die ermittelnden
behörden in portugal halten davon nicht
viel diese aufmerksamkeit macht ihrer
ansicht nach mehr kaputt als dass sie
hilft reporter kai feldhaus fährt nach
lissabon wo am nächsten morgen im hotel
auf den ehemaligen chefvermittler
goncalo amaral trifft kaum jemand kennt
den fall von anfang an so gut wie keiner
mehr als hallo amaral hat die
ermittlungen im fall maddie mccann von
anfang an geführt er war damals
kriminalkommissar und nachdem er aus dem
polizeidienst entfernt wurde nachdem er
von dem fall abgezogen wurde und den
vorzeitigen ruhestand geschickt wurde in
den großen ist aber und zurückgezogen
lebt jetzt hier in der nähe und hat von
sich aus vorgeschlagen dass jedem der ex
chef ermittler trägt einen gut sitzenden
anzug das hemd unter dem jackett ist
strahlend weiß er sieht ein wenig dem
trump anwalt rudy giuliani ähnlich
neusta meral jünger und deutlich
sympathischer wir haben die ermittlungen
angefangen
als kripo-chef ging ich nicht gleich zum
tatort das macht immer ein kollege wir
gingen an diesem fall genauso heran an
einen diebstahl als wäre etwas gestohlen
worden wie sind die täter an den tatort
gelangt wie sind sie wieder weg gibt es
ein bruch oder fingerabdrücke das war im
nachhinein ein fehler
[Musik]
ich hatte sehr bald das gefühl dass mit
den eltern etwas nicht stimmt nach
nationalen und internationalen
maßstäben sind die hauptverdächtigen im
fall des verschwindens eines kleinkindes
diejenigen die für seine betreuung und
sicherheit verantwortlich sein in diesem
fall die eltern
es ist normal dass sie von anfang an
verdächtig sind hier aber war es nicht
der fall hier hatte der botschafter ein
auge auf die situation des gab
politischen druck so dass die eltern von
anfang an nicht als verdächtiger
angesehen wurden es gibt eine aussage
die wirklich haarsträubend ist von john
tanner einer freundin der eltern sie
sagt sie habe das kind auf der straße
auf dem arm eines mannes gesehen die
aussage ist voller widersprüche
es ist eine lüge
gonzalo amaral ärgert es dass so eine
normale polizeiarbeit kaum möglich ist
permanent steht jemand hinter einem und
schaut auf jeden handgriff jede notiz
die ermittlungsarbeit wird unter diesem
politischen druck sehr schwierig
nach der ersten routineuntersuchung
wurde einen tag später eine umfassende
inspektion des tatorts durchgeführt bei
der auch nach haaren und anderen spuren
gesucht wurde
ich habe bis heute keine zweifel dass
eine entführung dort nur simuliert wurde
es gibt mehrere anzeichen dafür ein
fenster von dem niemand sicher sagen
konnte ob es offen oder geschlossen war
hinaus
es gab fingerabdrücke der mutter des
kindes die zeigen dass sie das fenster
geöffnet hat es war die einzige
es gab keine anzeichen dafür dass die
jalousie von außen aufgeschoben wurde
und auch sonst keine für einen einbruch
es wurde eine behauptete die nicht
stattgefunden
für den chefermittler ist es damals
zunehmend schwierig in diese richtung
weiter zu ermitteln er bleibt dennoch
hart und trotzt allen widrigkeiten
es werden zwar einige polizeibekannte in
sexualdelikten vorbestrafte verhaftet
die sich zu dieser zeit in portugal
aufhalten aber keiner dieser personen
kann etwas in bezug auf maddies
verschwinden nachgewiesen werden
zum ersten mal an dem appartement in
praia da luz vor gefahren bin saß dort
nur ein journalist mit einem laptop im
auto kurz danach war niemand mehr da und
nur stunden später war es als ginge die
welt unter ein unglaublicher zirkus
wurde aufgefahren wir hatten überhaupt
keine möglichkeiten mehr ungestört unter
vertrag zu arbeiten und warum all das es
gibt mehrere faktoren aber der
wichtigste ist sicher der wunsch der
eltern alles zu tun
heute ist amerell nicht mehr im
polizeidienst seien tiefer frust in
bezug auf die mccanns und die presse mit
der er nur noch in ausnahmefällen wie
diesem hier spricht ist verständlich
sehen wir uns den weiteren verlauf der
ermittlungen an
anfang august 2007 finden portugiesische
ermittler mit spürhunden reste von
blutspuren in der ferienwohnung amaral
vermutet maddie könnte am dritten mai
dort gestorben und ihre leiche dann
etwas später fortgeschafft worden sein
und es geht weiter die polizei findet in
einem leihwagen den kate mccann gemietet
hat weitere blutspuren
daraufhin werden die eltern im september
2007 nochmals verhört und zu
verdächtigen erklärt einem
veröffentlichten transkript nach soll
kate mccann keine der 48 an sie
gerichteten fragen in dem langen verhör
beantwortet haben nach ihrer rückkehr
nach großbritannien beschuldigten die
mccanns ihrerseits die portugiesischen
ermittler sie würden aussagen
provozieren wollen denen zufolge sie
ihre tochter versehentlich getötet und
die leiche später in ihrem leihwagen
beseitigt hätten
chefermittler gonzalo amaral dagegen
kritisiert die britischen ermittler hart
daraufhin wurde aus seinem amt entlassen
am 21 juli 2008 beendet die
portugiesische staatsanwaltschaft die
ermittlungen und stuft die mccanns nicht
mehr als verdächtiger ein am 24 juli
2008 veröffentlicht ex ermittler amaral
das buch aber da da dam and ihrer die
wahrheit der lüge darin folgt der these
maddie sei durch einen tragischen unfall
gestorben ihre eltern hätten eine
entführung vorgetäuscht und später die
leiche verschwinden lassen das ehepaar
mccann verklagte ihn wegen verleumdung
und lässt das buch vom markt nehmen
nachdem er von seinen aufgaben entbunden
wurde
mit dem medien gebrochen also hat sich
überall falsch dargestellt gefühlt das
heißt eigentlich redet er nicht mehr
deswegen bin ich jetzt sehr dankbar dass
2008 entschuldigen sich übrigens auch
die britischen zeitungen bei der familie
mccann für ihre berichte die ihnen eine
mitschuld am verschwinden und tod von
maddie unterstellen den mccanns werden
horrende entschädigungen zugesprochen
die sie aber nur für die weitere suche
nach ihrer tochter einsetzen am vierten
august 2008 veröffentlicht die
portugiesische polizei die
ermittlungsakten zu dem fall demnach
konnten forensiker die blutspuren im
leihwagen von kate mccann nicht
eindeutig mehr die zuordnen
2009 und 2015 verbieten zudem zwei
portugiesische gerichtsinstanzen dem
ehemaligen chefvermittler amaral den
verkauf seines buchs auch in portugal
amaral ist mit seiner betrachtung des
falls aber nicht allein die us
amerikanische fall analytikerin pat
brown veröffentlicht 2011 einen aufsatz
zum möglichen unfall tod des mädchens
und eine nachfolgende vertuschung durch
die eltern im april 2017 behauptet pat
brown zudem in einem blogbeitrag die
mccanns hätten die aussage des ehepaars
mit verschwiegen diese aussage auf die
auch amaral bezug nimmt erwähnt dass ein
mann mit einem kind auf dem arm der zum
strand ging durchaus maddies vater
gerald hätte sein können unterwegs um
sein kind dem meer zu übergeben es
bleiben grausige spekulationen beweise
gibt es dafür zu keinem zeitpunkt
goncalo amaral nippt an seinem espresso
außerhalb des hotel foyer es ist es
schon wieder brütend heiß geworden kai
feldhaus weiß dass amaral von den neuen
einlassungen der deutschen
staatsanwaltschaft gar nichts hält aber
er spricht ihn trotzdem darauf an denn
seit 2020 ermittelt man gegen einen
neuen hauptverdächtigen christian b
der name christian b war auf meiner
liste von menschen die ein gewisses
pädophiles profil aufweisen an der
gesamten algarve wurden teams gebildet
man hat an seine tür geklopft aber er
war nicht zu hause
jetzt kommt aber plötzlich deutschland
ins spiel die staatsanwaltschaft in
braunschweig sagt es gebe materielle
beweise dafür dass christian
der deutsche staatsanwalt sollte nicht
ständig behaupten dass etwas gegen
christian wie in der hand hat dann klagt
ihn an ringen vor gericht und dann
erklären wie jemand das am taten und
eingebrochen ist ohne finger april oder
spuren von handschuhen zu lassen erkläre
mir warum gab es keine einbruchspuren
warum war das fenstergriffe
christian b ist ein einzelgänger der
perfekte verdächtige mit all seinem
vorgeschichten vom vergewaltiger älterer
frauen bis zum kinderschänder nur weil
er nicht tot ist kommt der deutsche
staatsanwalt moment nicht weiter belebt
und hat einen anwalt er kann sich
verteidigen dem widersprechen wofür
angeschrieben
sie bringen
[Musik]
das gespräch mit uns alle war sinnvoll
und wichtig dass es auch noch mal die
andere seite dieses falles beleuchtet
und
das brutalo amaral ist ganz klar sagt
dieser mann das ist uns gelungen das ist
der ideale verdächtige den sie immer
gesucht haben und er hat erfüllt jetzt
nur diese rolle das erweitert zumindest
den blickwinkel auf den fall dass man
nicht vergessen sollte christian b ist
verdächtig aber noch längst nicht
angeklagt christian b wird uns in diesem
fall noch intensiv beschäftigen
vorerst wird bild reporter kai feldhaus
aber erst einmal mit dem mietwagen
zurück nach playa de los er braucht
etwas zeit zum nachdenken während er die
wundervolle küste betrachtet die algarve
ist aber auch ein rückzugsort sich viele
kleinkriminelle die ihre ruhe wollen ich
bin immer wieder selbst steckt an diesem
zwiespalt zu sehen die paradiese dadurch
verstehen dass dieser ort jetzt
stellvertretend steht für eines der
größten verbrechen die
kriminalgeschichte
so wichtig dann immer mal hitzfeld haus
erinnert sich erneut an das gespräch mit
dem profiler axel petermann in berlin
in ein appartement einsteigen das
bewohnt ist in dem kinder schlafen und
die eltern sind 50 meter wer tut denn so
was
also ich würde immer wenn ich eine
solche fragen beantworten sollte ganz
früh anfangen wie sind die familiären
verhältnisse
besteht die möglichkeit dass die tat
dort auch in der familie ihren ursprung
hatte und das war die sehr sehr genau
versuchen zu untersuchen um dann zu
sagen
die familie möchte ich ausschließen man
muss sich sehr genau mit den spuren die
es dort an diesem ort des verschwindens
gibt auseinandersetzen man muss sich mit
den einlassungen der betroffenen auf ein
anderer weg glauben sie dass wenn wir
diese hypothese folgen das ist eine
jemand von außen war
dass diese tat geplant war oder eher
eine zufalls tat jemand der einbrechen
wollte und plötzlich das stadtfest
stellte ob das noch ein kind sehen also
wenn es denn tatsächlich einmal in der
entführung handelt dann könnte ich mehr
er eine zufällige verfügung doch
vorstellen wenn man ein verdächtigen wie
christian brückner aber führen möchte wo
setzt man da an also ich möchte
möglichst viele informationen haben
natürlich die situation als ich das als
die tatsächliche ereignete will ich
genau wissen auch der lebensweg eines
menschen kann bedeutsamen sein
genau der lebensweg dieses mannes
christian b kai feldhaus kann gleich in
der nähe des ehemaligen tatorts mit der
suche nach der antwort auf eine frage
beginnen wer ist christian b
195 bis 2007 lebte der tatverdächtige
christian b in portugal dort ist jetzt
unser reporter hanna grafik auf einem
hügel also auch eine art krippe steht
auch diese baracke hier im hintergrund
wenn man die frage beantworten will wo
christian b auf diese entsetzlich
schiefe bahn geraten ist dann muss man
hier in anfangen zu suchen karl feldhaus
wird genau das tun er parkt seinen wagen
oberhalb der küstenlinie im gleißenden
licht kann über das langsam
austrocknende hinterland von praia da
luz schauen nachdenklich schüttelt der
journalistin kopf und setzt die
sonnenbrille auf
alles ist hier sehr eng beisammen
[Musik]
etwa der außenklasse
gleich hinter dieser krippe ist das haus
die startseite
sind weniger als fünf kilometer
luftlinie gut 20 minuten zu fuß wenn man
die strecke neu man bekommt ganz gutes
bild von den dimensionen
[Musik]
es ist das aber so einem kleinen örtchen
jemand verschwindet dann sollte es von
welchen tricks
[Musik]
wer ist christian b wer kannte ihn schon
damals wie ist er überhaupt nach
portugal gekommen dann geriet der junge
mann auf die schiefe bahn und das
wichtigste ist erde entführer und
vielleicht auch der mörder von maddie
mccann
diese fragen die uns näher zu einer
möglichen lösung des mysteriösen
entführungsfall führen können stellen
wir uns im zweiten teil dieser
doppelfolge an dieser stelle möchte ich
danke sagen dass ihr wieder dabei war
bei tatort deutschland bis bald sky
dumont
[Musik]
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler
drehbuch lutz neumann
redaktion bild kai feldhaus und stefan
netzeband